bienvenidos a reporteros el magazine de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de france 24 hoy los llevaremos a eeuu
desde principio de 2021 los cruces
ilegales en la frontera entre eeuu y
méxico han aumentado a un máximo en 20
años en menos de 12 meses las
autoridades detuvieron a más de 17
millones de inmigrantes este incremento
en las cifras se da desde la toma de
posesión del presidente joe by de quien
prometió deshacer una política de
inmigración restrictiva implementada por
su predecesor donald trump en washington
la oposición republicana acusa a su
administración de minimizar lo que llama
una crisis migratoria y en texas a
principios de este año el gobernador
greta bot declaró el estado de
emergencia para 28 condados estatales
fronterizos con méxico con la esperanza
de construir un muro con fondos
estatales por los cruces pasan en su
mayoría hombres solteros conectados con
traficantes pero también menores no
acompañados y familias los principales
países de donde provienen estos
ciudadanos son méxico honduras guatemala
el salvador haití y venezuela los
migrantes pueden solo para silos y han
sufrido persecución en su país de origen
debido a su raza religión nacionalidad u
opiniones políticas el reportaje que
veremos a continuación fue realizado en
río grande por los enviados especiales
fan y alar y que te bangor gestan y
[Música]
4 y 30 m primera alerta en las orillas
del río grande seguimos a las patrullas
americanas a pocos kilómetros de nuestra
posición un grupo acaba de ser
interceptar todos los que tengan un modo
de identificación para que puedan
presentar por favor estos hombres y
mujeres acaban de cruzar la frontera
ilegalmente méxico está a sólo unos
cientos de metros en el condado de
valverde las llegadas son diarias pero
aún más numerosas durante los fines de
semana como este domingo cuántos de
ustedes menores de 18
18 aunque
con 14 y 12
esta familia es originaria de venezuela
para llegar hasta aquí viajaron en
autobús o por 7 países
nosotros tenemos una semana y
imagínate
todo lo que nos dé noticias de venezuela
acabando con todo el trabajo en objeto
del trabajo porque somos opositores y
somos seguidores perdimos en la bolsa de
comida la gasolina que pagan en dólares
no hay beneficios no hay medicinas
miriam tiene 61 años y es la mayor de su
familia acompaña a su hijo su mujer y
sus cuatro hijos venir a los estados
unidos fue su idea así que agradece a
dios por haber llegado hasta ahí
muchas gracias señor muchas gracias
porque fuiste mi guiado los otros
miembros del grupo también son de
venezuela hace unas horas no conocían a
miriam y su familia se encontraron en la
orilla mexicana y cruzaron juntos el río
grande
aquí es un 15
pero aparentemente eran unos 50 dicen
que el resto del grupo siguió caminando
hacia allí los bienes si los tenemos que
tras ser detenido por la policía estatal
es la patrulla fronteriza la que se hace
cargo cuentan con niños hombres solteros
familias y aplican medidas de seguridad
en todos los zapatos
aquí en el sur de texas la mayoría del
personal de las fuerzas del orden habla
español a menudo son descendientes de
inmigrantes
cargados con unas cuantas maletas los
únicos fragmentos del país que les
quedan estos hombres y mujeres son
llevados a un centro de control donde se
examinará si pueden solicitar asilo
dejamos a miriam e y su familia sin
saber si los volveremos a ver en la
américa de iovine esta escena se ha
convertido
en washington la oposición republicana
acusa al gobierno de minimizar la
situación y no nombrar a lo que ella
llama una crisis en migratoria
desde principios de 2021 de las llegadas
ilegales a eeuu han aumentado hasta los
niveles más altos de los últimos 20 años
pero para henry cuellar demócrata
elegido para la cámara de representantes
de texas este no es un debate nuevo
lo vimos en 2014 con obama luego en 2019
con tramos y ahora lo estamos viendo con
bailes
diferentes hay más gente y eso es debido
a esta percepción de que la
administración está tomando medidas pro
y graciosas como rescindir el mpp
alguna medida que obligaba a los
solicitantes de asilo a esperar en
mexico para que el caso fuera procesados
before the kennedys first aid long en
eeuu los inmigrantes se pueden solicitar
asilo si han sido perseguidos en su país
por su raza religión nacionalidad u
opinión política esto no es suficiente
para el congresista que cree que estas
condiciones deberían ampliarse
con todo respeto cuando la
administración dijo no vengan ahora
vengan después fue un mensaje equivocado
muchas personas miren en eeuu para tener
una vida mejor pero esto no es una razón
para el asilo creo en la reforma de la
inmigración quiero que la gente venga de
la manera correcta
nuestro credo de la frontera es que
creemos en inmediaciones de galp pero
estamos en contra de la inmigración
ilegal y
promover la inmigración legal es también
el deseo de joe martínez el sheriff del
condado de val verde lleva tres décadas
en las fuerzas del orden y nunca se
había enfrentado a una situación de esta
magnitud en años anteriores hemos visto
gente cruzando pero mi oficina solía
ocuparse de dos o tres casos al mes que
habíamos visto algo así y tampoco
nuestros colegas de la policía federal
los comisarios son 24 por ronda y cubren
una zona de 8 millones de hectáreas que
comparte 177 kilómetros de frontera con
mexico suelen tener suficiente personal
pero desde principios de año el 75% de
su actividad se ha movilizado por la
llegada de inmigrantes y la asistencia a
la policía fronteras aquí es donde
entran los inmigrantes
entran arreglados
esta propiedad privada no está habitada
por ello esta tierra se ha convertido en
un punto de paso habitual para los
migrantes pero también porque el río
grande solo tiene 120 metros de ancho
aquí frente a méxico y detrás de esta
colina la ciudad hay personas que huyen
de su país porque su gobierno es
peligroso no están seguras en su país
así que quieren probar una nueva vida en
eeuu
por eso hacen este viaje y les deseo lo
mejor usted sabe que nosotros mismos
somos inmigrantes y me rompe el corazón
que no haya una solución obvia a este
problema
el sheriff o martínez es un ferviente
demócrata pero lamenta la falta de
recursos y una situación politizada por
los partidos que no aportan soluciones
si es una crisis la gente está muriendo
la administración en el mensaje de
apertura y sugirió que habría más
oportunidades para venir a eeuu
se le dan documentos legales a la espera
de que se tramite su solicitud de asilo
político que a veces tarda años
apenas terminada esta entrevista una
familia corre por el lado mexicano del
río grande ante nuestros ojos
el nivel del agua es bajo y les permite
cruzar a pie sin riesgo de ser
arrastrados por la corriente
no se esconden y caminan en nuestra
dirección la dirección de la policía
esta mujer está sin aliento
sólo unos pasos más
y estará en eeuu
por qué
y venezuela
rosario y enrique dejaron su país hace
un año antes de venir aquí vivieron
varios meses en colombia para ganar algo
de dinero
afirman que no pagaron a los carteles
mexicanos para que les ayudaran a cruzar
es imposible de verificar la mayoría de
las veces los migrantes no dicen nada
por miedo a las represalias
ya estamos en eso está el proceso el
proceso legal sabe y bueno no estamos
comunicando papá nos vemos pronto
llama hermano no abras
este es el país de las grandes
oportunidades y estamos muy contentos de
estar en este país que sabemos que todo
el que viene para acá tiene la
oportunidad que en otros lugares no la
hemos podido tener es bueno que
emigran con este nuevo presidente más
todavía
el gobierno nos atrevimos a hacerlo
como rosario y su marido en del río la
mayoría de los que llegan son familias
que quieren ser apoyadas por las
autoridades para completar su solicitud
de asilo pero más al sur de la frontera
es otra realidad los cruces también son
diarios pero conciernen a una mayoría de
hombres solteros a menudo vestidos con
uniforme camuflado y conectados con
contrabandistas
parece que este también lo han cortado
de algo así que mañana vendré a arreglar
marcos y stephanie canales son
agricultores el nieto de inmigrantes
mexicanos ella cuarta generación de
tejanos denunciar la destrucción de sus
recintos por lo que denominan bailout
persecuciones entre camionetas cargadas
de inmigrantes y carros de policía el
conductor coyote contrabandista lo que
sea recogió el grupo y conduce hacia el
norte ahí es donde normalmente las
fuerzas del orden los localizan así que
intentan escapar y ahí es donde saltan
las vallas conduciendo lo más rápido que
pueden y entonces se tiran del coche y
bien destrozan el vehículo bien el
vehículo acaba deteniéndose y eso es el
rescate los migrantes escapan y van en
diferentes direcciones a veces son cinco
o seis personas a menudo son 10 15 18
personas una vez no muy lejos de aquí un
vehículo llevaba incluso 35 personas
transportan el mayor número de personas
posible porque el contrabandista cobra
por persona así que cuanta más gente
haya
dinero abra estas persecuciones se
producen varias veces a la semana y hace
unos días un vehículo fue abandonado en
las tierras de los agricultores aquí es
donde se dispersan todas aquí se ven
objetos que dejaron móviles aquí se ven
todos los daños y aquí está el camión
marcus canales se muestra preocupado por
la falta de seguridad debido a la
permeabilidad de la frontera en su
condado las detenciones han aumentado
considerablemente desde principios de
año hace tres días detuvieron a un tipo
que ya había sido condenado por
violación y que intentaba volver lo
detuvieron con un grupo de personas
puesto que no son todos así pero cuando
estás en una vegetación tan densa en
medio de la nada como nosotros y ves
entran 15 personas quien es bien
intencionado y quién no cómo puedo
saberlo si no los conozco
al igual que su padre de stephany cría
ganado en su granja de 1600
nació aquí y nunca ha salido de la
frontera por lo que está acostumbrada a
ver a la gente cruzar sin embargo
denuncia una situación de descontrol
todos estamos a favor de la inmigración
legal en este país
realmente lo apoyo
pero no se puede dejar entrar a la gente
sin saber de dónde vienen qué quiere
hacer aquí vendiendo
muchos terratenientes y agricultores de
la frontera sienten que el gobierno no
les escucha ni entiende sus
preocupaciones
porque ni siquiera admite que hay un
problema y nosotros somos los que lo
vivimos día a día
a principios de este año el gobernador
de texas greg abbott os declaró el
estado de emergencia para 28 condados de
la frontera con méxico con la esperanza
de construir un muro con fondos
estatales en línea con el plan de donald
trump en el río nos encontramos por
casualidad con miriam la mujer más vieja
que conocimos durante la noche el nombre
de una asociación se hace cargo de ella
y espera reunirse con el resto de su
familia aún en manos de la publicidad de
fronteras para verlo están chequeando
allá y lo traen en la tarde pero ya yo
estoy lista demócratas y republicanos se
enfrentan por la cuestión migratoria y
parecen estar convirtiendo una crisis
humanitaria en una crisis política una
cosa es cierta la inmigración es uno de
los principales retos del mandato de
iovine
hasta aquí reporteros recuerde para
sintonizar este y los programas
anteriores puede visitar nuestra página
web france24 puntocom
hasta la próxima
[Música]